hey I think now is a good time to answer
some of your questions from social media
how do leaders maintain optimism when
they are tired if you've ever been in a
position of leadership you know that
leadership can be extremely lonely
sometimes it's hard to relate to folks
on your team and you definitely can't
just come to work or show up on your
team and just start crying and venting
it just won't work and so it can be kind
of isolating so one of the most
important things any effective leader
has to do is maintain their close
friendships you have to have people that
you can go to to vent to cry to let it
all out where it's a safe environment
where you're not giving instructions or
telling people this is the end of the
organization but rather you just need to
get it all out of you have those
cathartic experiences in fact I take it
super seriously I have a rule with my
friends that there's no crying alone and
so if any one of us is ever completely
overwhelmed we call each other and say
do you have a minute I just need to vent
or I just need to cry or I just need to
get this out and amazingly that gets us
right back on the path of optimism so
how do leaders maintain their ability to
stay optimistic in the hardest hardest
hardest of times maintain your personal
relationships your friends will always
be there for you
so here's a question that came in from
online how do you as an employer signal
to employees to maintain an infinite
mindset and if you're looking for a job
how do you tell if an employer has an
infinite mindset well like any kind of
vision or anything like that
communication is key great organizations
use every opportunity they're packaging
their marketing their sales materials if
you have a a retail experience with
another human being all those
opportunities to talk to people Infuse
the message all the time and so great
companies you can tell because it's all
around us the leaders will talk about it
in meetings I bring up our infinite
mindset and our vision all the time in
all of our meetings I never assume that
everybody knows it so the easiest way to
signal to people is to constantly
constantly talk about it and if you're
looking for a job and you want to work
for an infinite minded company go look
at the things that their Executives have
said in the Press go look at the way
they write about themselves on their
website go look at their marketing go
look at their advertising and you should
be able to form a picture if they have a
long-term view of the world or not
and I can give you an amazing example of
that when I wrote start with why all
those years ago I had this whole theory
about Apple and how they saw the world
and how Steve Jobs saw the world now I
put that together from all public
resources from their marketing their
packaging everything the store
experience because when I tried to
interview Steve Jobs just by bad luck my
publisher had published an unauthorized
biography of Steve Jobs a year or two
before and so Apple basically
blacklisted anybody that came out of
that publisher the mere fact that I was
associated with them they wouldn't talk
to me and so the only resource I had was
public statements and because apple and
Steve Jobs were so consistent about
their beliefs and how they viewed the
world I was able to accurately capture
how they actually viewed the world so
great companies talk about it constantly
and consistently
what if you work for somebody who's a
know-it-all or at least presents
themselves as knowing at all how do you
deal with that well the best way is to
Simply ask a question let's say they
tell you what they think you can add can
I add something to that in most cases
people who present themselves who as
know-it-alls simply think out loud or
they think they're helping or they can't
help themselves so by you asking can I
add something to that you'll probably
find that many of them will be very
welcoming of your ideas and that way you
get to contribute and not feel
steamrolled so I got this question
recently what is symbolic about the
color orange and if you know my work
from over the years you'll always notice
that there's always a little bit of
orange somewhere on my person well the
reason is simple they're reminders I am
human and sometimes I forget my own
cause I forget my own why I forget why
I'm doing this I get sucked into the
details of the Daily Grind and by
looking at the color orange it reminds
me to be bright and optimistic and so
it's a symbol of my cause it's a symbol
of what I believe and it serves as a
little bit of a reminder to me as well
Orange
love Orange
so I get asked this question a lot like
what's inspiring me right now and I give
the same answer all the time which is
where I find inspiration is usually in
Darker Corners that most people aren't
looking there are people out there doing
remarkable things who are putting
themselves out and serving people at
Great personal sacrifice and whenever I
get to meet those people or hear about
those people quite frankly that's
inspiring that's one of the reasons I
started a bit of optimism that's one of
the reasons I started my podcast is
because I felt I was being selfish that
I was reaching out to these wonderful
people who inspired me and I wanted to
share those conversations and that's why
the podcast is so conversational it's
legitimately me being curious about
these wonderful people doing wonderful
things and just get to share it so I
guess one of the things that's inspiring
me these days is the wonderful people
who we have on a bit of optimism
this question comes up uncomfortably a
lot which is how can not-for-profits how
can non-profits better communicate their
mission okay let's set something
straight first of all non-profit is a
tax delineation it's how the IRS looks
at charities and what drives me crazy is
when these organizations call themselves
non-profit you're defining Yourself by
what you're not you just Define profit
differently for example you may not be
doing it for the money but you're doing
it for something if your mission is to
rescue kittens from trees then I hope
you rescue more kittens this month than
last month that's your profit more more
you're doing more of the thing you said
you're going to do
not-for-profit organizations need to
call themselves for impact organizations
it's better to be for something and
that's one of the best ways to
communicate talk about what you're for
not what you're against the joke is is
that whether you're for-profit or
not-for-profit all the same rules of
marketing and communication are all
exactly the same speaking inspiring
terms talk about your vision and talk
about what you're doing and invite
others who believe what you believe to
come and contribute whether they give to
you buy from you or work for you
here's a good question that somebody
asked as a leader what's the difference
between I'm here to support and how can
I help now I don't usually like going
down semantic boulevards and talking
about and parsing out the difference
between you know these two words as I
view them I think it all is based on the
relationship quite frankly if somebody
you get along with and Trust says how
can I help or how can I support you're
going to receive it the same way and
some of you don't really trust says it
it's going to be disingenuous now one of
the things I do like to do is I like to
use the word what when it comes to
support instead of how can I support
tell me what I can do to support you
tell me what I can do to help you in
other words I make it that it's a yes
and no answer like I make it that
there's something specific as opposed to
asking how can I help which is usually a
bit flowery and people don't know how to
answer that one so even when I call my
friends for example I never say I'll be
there if you need me I always say I'll
be there when you need me
um weirdly enough those little changes
in language make it more immediate and
make it more real
here's a good question when should you
give up a leadership position or a
leadership role now leadership comes at
Great personal sacrifice that's part of
the deal of being a leader it's hard
it's sometimes thankless and the reason
we do it is because we believe in the
cause and we have these little glimmers
that make all of that worth it now the
problem is if it gets the point where
you don't feel it's worth it or you
don't feel that you can contribute then
yes sometimes it is good to step aside
from being the leader and maybe let
somebody else stand in or if you need to
take a leave of absence from that role
that works too it is tiring but it you
are not a martyr when you are a leader
you don't do it to the point of such
tremendous self-sacrifice that you
actually hurt yourself yes you're going
to go through more stress than most but
not completely to it to the point where
it shuts down the system so like
anything pay attention to yourself pay
attention to your body even just taking
time off as a leader you can say I'm
taking a week off and I'm not checking
back in I need to reset and by the way
that sends a remarkable message to your
team if you actually come out and say
I'm stressed out of my head and I just
need to reset for a long weekend what it
says to your team is that they have
permission to do the same to come to you
and say I'm struggling can I take a long
weekend so you're actually being a great
leader by ensuring that you're taking
time to look after yourself as well so
this question is a really good one what
are some of the rules of humanity that
are immune from technology really easy
physical touch a hug a handshake even
looking someone dead in the eye right
you may feel that I'm looking you in the
eye right now I'm looking down the
barrel of a camera right I'm not feeling
any connection right now so when we're
together no matter what the technology
is around us physical contact sitting
next to somebody hugging somebody
nothing replaces that which is why it's
so damn wonderfully valuable and special
so how do you know if you actually
inspired someone easy answer they'll
tell you when people are inspired they
feel the need to reach out and say thank
you they feel the need to say that was
inspiring so as long as you're doing
what you're doing and putting your
message out there you'll get plenty of
feedback I promise
so you may know that I'm a big Lego fan
there's some right behind me in fact
there's lots behind me
um what's my favorite set that I've ever
built there's actually two one is the
grand piano oh so much fun and the other
one is the Nintendo NES system that was
so incredibly fun a there's like working
stuff that you have to make it work it
like takes the cartridge and goes down
it's so fantastic and it wasn't
monotonous I found the one I find the
ones that repeat a little bit monotonous
those were two of my absolute favorite
sets to build I'm really looking forward
to building the full size at ads the Big
Star Wars uh Walker thing but it is huge
and I've been putting it off and putting
it off because it's going to take me so
long to do it and I just need a big
chunk of time but I'm really looking
forward to doing that one so yeah grand
piano and Nintendo NES system if you get
hold of it you'll never have more fun
seriously never
um the leaders that have inspired me the
most are people quite frankly that I've
written about I got to meet them I wrote
about them and some of them I became
friends with I've written about Bob
Chapman I've written about Johnny Bravo
I've written about Ron Bruder quite
frankly when I meet people who are
inspiring I want to share their stories
so yeah a lot of the people I write
about are the people that have that
either have or continue to inspire me
okay let's talk about remote work I know
we've been talking about it for like two
years but what is the role of remote
work and can it work in building strong
organizations I think we're starting to
see some of the evidence that it is
backfiring a little bit I know a lot of
mostly young people older people too but
excuse younger that they really like
remote work because they like their
independence they like working from home
they like building this new life
especially ones that especially young
people who have never actually had an
in-person job they graduated college
doing covet and just started working but
the reality is it's starting to have a
negative impact we're starting to see
disconnection we're starting to see
people feeling lonely we're starting to
see problems in Innovation and idea
generation and quite frankly there's no
better way to communicate with fellow
team members and create an esprita core
than in person looking somebody eye to
eye so I think the the the time of a
hundred percent remote work it's not
here to stay I think at the at the very
minimum you're gonna see
um remote where there are remote
companies where they're going to be have
business trips off sites visiting each
other that kind of thing is healthier
but yeah
we're human beings we want to be around
with human beings and for us to be
productive and trusting we need to form
relationships and the best relationships
are formed in person